my landlord refuses to freeze my rent
during cost of living crisis I don't
know how I'm going to pay it is
absolutely appalling that you know rent
is continually increasing and people
have to face either paying it or being
evicted and facing homelessness I I
understand I mean the situation is as
I'm sure you're aware is that right now
interest rates are going up so if
interest rates are going up without
increasing rents then a landlord is
going to be
is going to be out of pocket in my
opinion landlords took on that burden of
responsibility when they bought the home
a lot a lot of people will say to
tenants well get a second job then so
maybe landlords should do the same thing
do you think the interest rate should be
frozen sure but then but then the reason
they've put interest rates up is to
bring down inflation so your your theory
I'm not I'm sure you're coming from a
good place but it's it's where where is
that ever worked I'm I'm not an
economist so I but it hasn't